I'll be very honest one of the reasons I
didn't see Madagascar in the theaters is
because I thought the characters were
lamely designed maybe I was just too
used to the Disney stuff but I just
thought they looked kind of cheap so I
didn't see it or any of the sequels and
I avoided it for a while but when dream
worked you wear a yam still called it
that came around naturally I had to
watch it you know what it wasn't that
bad I think the real strength of it
comes from the animation the humor and
the fact that I legitimately didn't know
where it was going and I love movies
that can do that especially considering
where it started out in a zoo we see a
lion a zebra a giraffe and a hippo the
zebra played by Chris Rock is anxious to
get out of his environment into the wild
and a group of penguins are planning to
escape the zoo and head for the
Antarctic and advise him to follow his
dream and break out as well but his
friend a lion played by Ben Stiller a
giraffe played by David Schwimmer and a
hippo played by Jada pinkett-smith don't
keep a close enough eye on him and allow
him to escape this forces them to try
and hunt him down which results of them
getting captured thrown in boxes and
accidentally ending up on a deserted
island well mostly deserted is a tribe
of rodents led by Sacha Baron Cohen who
see their new friends as an opportunity
to keep them safe away from other
predators but that might be a little
complicated when the lion it turns out
may actually slowly be turning into a
predator himself so I'm not gonna lie
when I saw the first few minutes of this
I said to myself okay I got this figure
this is just gonna be the
fish-out-of-water story the friends are
gonna be angry at each other the tribes
gonna think they're one thing then we're
gonna do that stupid liar revealed story
and it's gonna suck blob of lie hope
there's some good jokes but actually no
there's no liar revealed story at all
the focus actually comes down to whether
or not the lion will give in to his
temptation and actually start eating his
friends you know what I haven't seen
that I think that's much more
interesting much more fun and much more
creative and I think it's made even
stronger by the fact that the for them
actually do seem to have a legitimate
camaraderie to a point where it actually
sort of start to remind me of the wild
yeah which one of these came out first
is this another bug's life and ants
thing all over again
well anyway the one thing this has over
the while is this
speed of the animation I mean there is
just a lot of energy to it and they're
trying hard to make the comedy come from
just the mere movement of them and a
good chunk of the time it really works
penguins are also a lot of fun and as
expected they pretty much steal the show
everything they do is sort of like
ninjas or secret agents I seen both
spin-off shorts and a spin-off series
based on these characters and you can
definitely see why but very enjoyable
I don't think Madagascar is anything
fantastic I will admit it did have me
laughing a lot of the time the story did
sort of have me guessing and it's
definitely bright and colorful it has a
lot of great stuff for kids I think it's
a pretty decent family flick it's smart
it's funny it's entertaining I don't
think it's a classic by any means but I
think it's a lot of fun
I take I'll see it but judging by the
number of sequels every made out of it
you probably already had two so you've
already drawn your own conclusions me
personally I'm glad I saw it and then
surprisingly even looking forward to
seeing the sequels but only if there's
more penguins
they like to move it move it you like to
move it move it breathe two one